Speaker 1: This is an absolutely wacky story. We
have now learned that Donald Trump was going to
appoint his daughter, Ivanka, to be president of
the World Bank until Steven Mnookin intervened.
There are a number of reports explaining that
back in 2019, Donald Trump told The Atlantic about
all the jobs that he wanted to give his daughter
Ivanka, even ones where she wouldn't be qualified
for an internship. And we have learned, per the
Intercept, that the idea was What about Ivanka?
As President of the World Bank in January of
2019, you might remember that Jim Yong Kim
announced he would be stepping down from
his role as president of the World Bank,
going to a very cushy gig on Wall Street at a
private equity firm as the White House moved
to select its new leader. One name very dear to
Trump's heart, kept floating around his daughter,
Ivanka. It never came to fruition, with Ivanka
later telling reporters that though her father
raised the subject, she declined to pursue
it because she was happy with her work
as senior adviser. But two sources not authorized
to speak publicly tell The Intercept that it
went well beyond Beltway chatter, Trump
wanted Ivanka as World Bank president,
but it was Treasury Secretary Steven Mnuchin
who blocked her getting into that role.
Spokespeople for Manchin and Ivanka didn't
respond to The Intercept's request for comment.
Neither did. Neither did the World Bank or the
Trump Organization. She didn't end up doing it,
but she did end up helping Stephen Mnookin
and then chief of Staff Mick Mulvaney
to choose the successor. How can anyone seriously
talk about Hunter Biden when these are the things
that Donald Trump was thinking of doing, and to
some degree, he was actually doing these things? I
mean, remember, I think it was at the G-20 or the
G-8 G8. I believe Ivanka sat in for then Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson at a G8 meeting. That's
insane. Remember the cringe worthy video where
Ivanka awkwardly sidled up to this conversation
with the chair of the International Monetary Fund,
Christine Lagarde, and German Chancellor Angela
Merkel and British Prime Minister Theresa May and
French President Emmanuel Macron at the G20? And
everybody just looked kind of uncomfortably and
said, what? That what? Why, why is Ivanka here?
Lagarde, in particular, seemed disgusted by it.
And it makes no sense that Ivanka would
even be considered for such a role.
The depths of corruption and nepotism and the
self-serving instincts of the Trump family
really know no bounds. And for me, the only
certain it's not surprising Trump thought of
this. It's not surprising he wanted to do it. The
only surprising thing to me is that Trump allowed
himself to be talked out of it by Stephen Mnookin,
when Steven Mnookin is the voice of reason.
You know, you must be coming up with a really bad
idea. And truly, I mean, as far as management is
concerned, I've always seen Mnookin more as an
opportunist. The guy is not dumb at all. He's just
an opportunistic finance guy. Socially awkward,
strange delivery willing to work for Trump for
what he saw as his own personal gain for which he
deserves criticism, for sure. But by the standards
of kind of like modern education and what's
appropriate, etc. Steven Mnuchin pretty smart guy.
And it's not a surprise that Manchin realized the
absurdity of what Donald Trump was thinking here,
but the the nepotistic instincts of Trump really
know no bounds. And when when we consider,
particularly in the context of it, Hunter is the
problem. The problem is Hunter Biden. And then we
see, I mean, listen, Kushner and Ivanka. We're
senior advisers to Trump. Imagine for a moment
if Joe Biden announced that Hunter Biden was
going to become his senior adviser or I mean,
imagine for a second if at a G-8 instead, instead
of the actual secretary of state, there was
video and there were pictures released of Hunter
Biden sitting there where the secretary of state
is actually supposed to be sitting. It would
be, what, a week, two weeks, three weeks.
They did seven to 10 days on Dr. Seuss, on Fox
News. Just imagine. And Trump wanted Ivanka as
president of the World Bank. And if he comes back
in 2024, I'm telling you right now the degree to
which the nepotism and the self-serving and the
corruption will increase is inconceivable to us.
It will be insane if he is rewarded with a second
term what we will see in terms of the nepotism.
Let's hope it doesn't happen. But very
good reporting there from The Intercept
and Vanity Fair and others. We'll have more on
this on The David Pakman Show Instagram. You can
find us on Instagram The David Pakman Show. You
can find me on Instagram at David Pakman as well.